Las Vegas is known for being the leading
City in entertainment to Mega Music and
sporting events taking Center Stage this
weekend from Taylor Swift to the NCAA
March Madness Tournament Madison
Kimbrough is live from the strip with a
scoop on it all
yeah every weekend in Vegas is busy but
this weekend really brought it all with
sports fans at T-Mobile Arena to tailor
fans wearing cowboy boots sequins and
pink take a look
my buddies and I back in the days to go
to the Western regionals every year and
haven't been probably about 10 or 15
years so it's excited that it's in Vegas
and uh come down and check it out sports
fans loving every minute of March
Madness here in Las Vegas
Saturday's game at T-Mobile Arena left
the Yukon Huskies howling as they
delivered a win with almost a 30-point
lead against the Gonzaga Bulldogs
people taking notice that Vegas is
quickly becoming more than just the
entertainment capital of the world as if
that weren't enough our city now has
some major stakes in the Sports World
too between T-Mobile and Allegiant I
mean I know in a couple years the final
four is going to be at Allegiant so
that's going to be coming up too so just
to get these events I'm looking forward
to 28 when you guys are hosting the
finals that will be a fantastic event
speaking of fantastic events
it's the second night of Taylor Swift's
heiress tour Swift being the first woman
to headline at Allegiant Stadium since
it opened in 2020 and swifties are ready
for it coming to Vegas is always super
exciting and the heiress tour
specifically because it's it's
everything combined it's not just one
you really get it all I grew up with
Taylor Swift so you know it's like oh my
gosh she's right there you know it was
awesome so we went and waited in the
merch lines again just to get the
specific shirt
as for arena and Stadium traffic fans
sharing that it wasn't too bad many
deciding to use Rideshare to avoid the
parking Hassle and fees reporting live
Addison Kimbrough 8 News Now